Studio ist Peter Thiede Deutschlands
schnellste Meinung wird heute hier zum
Tragen kommen und man muss sagen diese
Pressekonferenz kommt natürlich auch zu
einer ja muss man sagen etwas Unzeit für
den Kanzler selber in den Umfragen
abgestürzt das Volk steht offenbar nicht
mehr ganz hinter ihm ne nein also die
SPD ist wirklich abgeschmiert konstant
unter 20%, das kann dem Kanzler nicht
gefallen und offensichtlich gefällt
ihnen deutschen nicht was der Kanzler
macht deswegen muss er jetzt tatsächlich
viele Fragen beantworten zu den vielen
Krisen ob sie ob sie Krieg gegen die
Ukraine ist ob es die Gaskrise ist ob es
die hohen Strompreise sind die
grassieren Inflation also die Deutschen
haben mehr Sorgen als dass sie lachen
können und da brauchen müssen Kanzler
mal klare Worte finden dafür ist der
Termin gut aber wir kennen diese
Veranstaltung es kann auch abstrus
werden ja wir sehen also Olaf Scholz der
schon Platz genommen hat daneben sein
Regierungssprecher Hebestreit und der
Leiter der Bundespressekonferenz da
werden jetzt noch Fotos gemacht ganz
legere der Kanzler ohne Krawatte dort
auch schon gesehen gerade
die
sommerpressekonfer sitzen der Kanzlerin
Angela Merkel die war ja auch immer sehr
voll und beliebt weil sie da durchaus
auch mal den ein oder anderen Schatz
rausgelassen hat also sie hatten
staatshaus gelassen und der berühmteste
Satz der jemals in einer dieser
sommerpressekonferenzen gefallen ist in
ist wir schaffen das wir sehen hier noch
wird eingeleitet also noch verpassen wir
nichts weil gibt vorher immer noch mal
die Vorstellung was ist die
Bundespressekonferenz und dann wird
gleich an den Kanzler übergeben aber das
ist normalerweise da kann der Kanzler
gute Laune machen und da die Fragen
nicht nach komplexen sortiert sind wie
sonst in in einer Pressekonferenz kann
der Kanzler tatsächlich von Thema zum
Thema hüpfen und jeder Fragesteller hat
nur eine Frage eine Nachfrage das heißt
erste Frage einfach nicht beantworten
und bei der zweiten dann noch mal
rumeiern schon ist man aus dem Thema
raus gucken ob der Kanzler das so kann
wie Frau Merkel ich würde sagen jetzt
hören wir rein wir geben ab los geht's
willkommen Olaf Scholz ist das kannst Du
das erste Mal bei uns aber er ist
natürlich nicht das erste Mal in der
Bundespressekonferenz unser Büro hat man
nachgezählt sie waren schon 33 mal bei
uns
und zwar 23 mal als Finanzminister sechs
Mal als Arbeits- und Sozialminister
einmal als Generalsekretär und zwar
zweimal als kommissarischer SPD-Chef und
einmal als Hamburger Bürgermeister
bevor Sie mit dem kurzen
Eingangsstatement beginnen und wir zu
den Fragen kommen möchte ich für alle
die diese Pressekonferenz live sehen und
im Stream und ich wissen was die
Bundespressekonferenz ist noch kurz
erklären was wir sind die
Bundespressekonferenz ist ein
unabhängiger Verein von Journalistin und
Journalisten die aus Berlin über die
Bundespolitik berichten unser Aufgabe
ist es Pressekonferenzen zu veranstalten
und diese Pressekonferenzen dienen und
jetzt zitiere ich mal aus unserer
Satzung einer sachlichen an Tatsachen
orientierten und fairen Vermittlung von
politischen Informationen Aussagen und
Position
und damit Herr Scholz haben sie das Wort
bitteschön
schönen Dank schönen Dank für die
Einladung zu dieser
Bundespressekonferenz und die
Gelegenheit ein bisschen über alle
Themen die sie bewegen zu sprechen und
die natürlich auch die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger unseres Landes umtreiben wir
haben ernste Zeiten das glaube ich weiß
jeder und jeder in diesem Land ernste
Zeiten die uns auch noch viel
abverlangen werden was diesen Winter und
das nächste Jahr betrifft aber es ist
auch so dass wir jetzt in diesem Sommer
ein bisschen spüren dass es den Urlaub
gibt dass man ein bisschen das schöne
Wetter und die Zeit genießen kann und
ich habe den Eindruck dass viele Bürger
und Bürger das auch tun ich jedenfalls
habe mich in meinem Urlaub gut erholt
ich hoffe Sie haben das in ihrem auch
oder steht ihnen noch bevor im übrigen
ist es so dass wir viele Themen haben
die wir gleich diskutieren wollen ein
paar will ich ansprechen die größte
Herausforderung ist natürlich der
furchtbare Krieg den Russland gegen die
Ukraine begonnen hat und der jetzt nun
schon so viele Monate Wert und
unverändert verlangt dass wir
weitreichende zu treffen um die Ukraine
in ihrem Kampf und Unabhängigkeit zu
unterstützen wir tun das wie Sie wissen
durch ein massiven Bruch mit bisheriger
Praxis in dem wir Waffen liefern sehr
sehr viele sehr weitreichende sehr
effiziente und das werden wir auch die
nächste Zeit weiter tun wir unterstützen
die Ukraine finanziell und wir haben uns
darauf eingestellt dass das was mit
diesem Krieg verbunden ist die ganze
Welt berührt aber selbstverständlich
auch Europa und unser Land da geht es
insbesondere um Preisentwicklung aber
auch um die Energieversorgung und die
Herausforderung die damit verbunden sind
deshalb ist es so
dass wir uns genau auf diese Situation
intensiv vorbereitet haben ich habe
bereits im Dezember das letzten Jahres
kaum dass ich Kanzler geworden war im
Wirtschaftsministerium gefragt was
passiert eigentlich wenn uns plötzlich
kein Gas mehr geliefert wird ich habe
das auch im Kanzleramt recherchieren
lassen und meine Feststellung zu der
Zeit war diese Frage hat sich wohl
offenbar bis dahin niemand so richtig
gestellt und sie auch niemand zu Ende
beantwortet deshalb war es wichtig dass
wir noch vor Kriegsbeginn angefangen
haben dafür zu sorgen dass wir uns auf
diese Situation vorbereiten und wir
haben seither viele Entscheidungen
getroffen die aus dieser Vorbereitung
stammen schnell flüssiggast Terminals an
den norddeutschen Küsten zu bauen
Gesetze zu ändern dass das auch wirklich
schnell geht die entsprechenden
technischen Infrastrukturen zu
beschaffen insbesondere was
regazifizierungsanlagen betrifft wir
haben dafür gesorgt dass wir die
Speicher voll kriegen indem wir Gesetze
gemacht haben die genau das regeln
anders als im ja so dass wir jetzt
erwarten dürfen dass sie viel voller sie
sind jetzt ja schon viel voller als im
letzten Jahr und sie werden auch weiter
gefüllt werden wir haben dafür gesorgt
dass Kraftwerke Kohlekraftwerke wieder
in Betrieb genommen werden können die
ersten tun das bereits mit den übrigen
Betreibern sind wir nach den
gesetzlichen Veränderungen die wir
bewirkt haben jetzt im Gespräch und wir
prüfen ob es Sinn macht und erforderlich
ist die drei vorhandenen Atomkraftwerke
noch etwas länger laufen zu lassen das
wird bald festgestellt werden können
wenn die entsprechende Untersuchungen
abgeschlossen sind also eine intensive
Vorbereitung auf die Situation die uns
jetzt bevorsteht genauso wie die
Entscheidung die wir getroffen haben um
dann die Bürgern und Bürger zu entlasten
das erste und das zweite
Entlastungspaket von insgesamt 30
Milliarden Euro ist noch nicht
vollständig umgesetzt viele der
Maßnahmen sind breit diskutiert worden 9
euro-ticket die
zeitlich befristete Ersparnis an den
Tankstellen durch Verzicht aber
selbstverständlich auch die vielen
anderen Leistungen die zum Beispiel mit
einer Anhebung des Grundfreibetrags der
arbeitnehmerpauschale der
Pendlerpauschale verbunden sind mit
Direktzahlungen an Familien mit 100 Euro
für jedes Kind 20 Euro für arme Kinder
monatlich mit 200 Euro für
Grundsicherungsempfänger eine
Heizkostenpauschale die wir auf den Weg
gebracht haben und natürlich der
umfassenden Abschaffung der
EEG-Umlage seit mitte diesen Jahres was
den Strompreis von einer steuerlichen
Belastung von etwa 20 Milliarden Euro
befreit hat die bisher dort jedes Jahr
angefallen ist das sind diese Maßnahmen
aber wir werden neben dem notwendigen
Energiesparen dass wir alle machen damit
wir gut durch diese Zeit kommen und den
Entlastungsmaßnahmen die wir für die
Bürger und Bürger bisher ergriffen haben
auch weitere ergreifen müssen und dazu
ist die Regierung auch fest entschlossen
ich habe das zusammengefasst mit der
Formulierung you'll never walk alone und
das will ich auch hier noch einmal
wiederholen wir werden alles dafür tun
dass die Bürgern und Bürger durch diese
schwierige Zeit kommen mir geht es dabei
um diejenigen die ganz wenig haben und
deshalb haben wir gesagt wir wollen beim
Wohngeld was machen beim Bürgergeld und
sind dabei intensiv diese in Form
vorzubereiten wir haben gesagt wir
wollen was für diejenigen machen die ein
Arbeitseinkommen haben aber auch rechnen
müssen die keine Ersparnisse haben die
mit den plötzlichen gestiegenen
Energiekosten zum Beispiel nicht ohne
weiteres umgehen können und für die die
höheren heizrechnungen was ausmachen das
gilt für ganz ganz viele Bürger und
Bürger es gibt mehr um diejenigen die 28
verdienen 3.200 Euro brutto im Monat
4000 Euro für die das alles große
Herausforderungen sind und deshalb ist
klar dass zu dem Gesamtpaket dass wir
ergreifen werden sicherlich auch
steuerliche Entlastungsmaßnahmen
dazugehören der Finanzminister hat
seinen Beitrag zu den notwendigen
Überlegungen dazu gestern vorgestellt
ich finde das sehr sehr hilfreich weil
wir ja ein Gesamtpaket schnüren müssen
dass alle Bevölkerungsgruppen
fast diejenigen die breite
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung die geringe
oder normale Einkommen hat Rentner und
Rentner Studierende und das wird auch am
Ende das Gesamtpaket dieser Regierung
sein damit niemand alleine gelassen wird
niemand vor unlösbare Probleme gestellt
wird und keiner die Herausforderung die
mit den gestiegenen Preisen verbunden
sind alleine schultern muss
zwei letzte kurze Bemerkung mit all den
Entscheidungen die wir jetzt wegen des
Krieges zu treffen haben
ist nicht verbunden dass wir unsere
übrigen Vorhaben aufgeben sie wissen
dass es zum ersten Oktober die Anhebung
des Mindestlohns auf 12 Euro geben wird
sie wissen dass wir uns
bereits auf den Weg gebracht haben das
Erwerbsminderungsrentner mehr Geld
bekommen das ist gesetzlich beschlossen
wir werden die Rente stabilisieren wir
werden den Wohnungsbau voranbringen wir
haben massiv zusätzliche Mittel für
sozialen Wohnungsbau bereitgestellt all
diese Dinge kommen die wir uns
vorgenommen haben und das wird auch für
die Zukunft weiter wichtig sein denn das
ist auch einer der großen eine der
großen Herausforderungen die wir haben
und die andere Schlussbemerkung
die industrielle Modernisierung die
wohlstandssicherung Deutschlands die
Sicherstellung unserer Unabhängigkeit
und Autonomie das ist das zentrale
gemeinsame Reformvorhaben dieser
Regierung und deshalb haben wir schon
eine ganze Reihe von gesetzespaketen auf
den Weg gebracht mit dem wir den
schnellen Ausbau der Windkraft in
Deutschland an Land und auf hoher See
der Solarenergie der Stromnetze
rechtlich absichern und gesetzlich auf
den Weg bringen und vorschreiben wir
werden dieses Tempo fortsetzen das gilt
auch für den Umbau der Industrien ob es
nun die Automobilindustrie ist die
Stahlindustrie die Chemieindustrie
Dezember Industrie ist die eine andere
Grundlage brauchen für ihre Art und
Weise der Produktion und die das tun
wollen und was wir Ihnen dazu
versprechen müssen ist ein gutes Umfeld
in großer Menge bezahlbare Energie
insbesondere Strom und Wasserstoff aus
erneuerbaren Quellen und genau das tun
wir wir arbeiten sämtliche Versäumnisse
der letzten Jahre ab die in dieser
Hinsicht wirklich groß waren weil es
gemeinsame Entscheidung gab über
Ausstiege aus Kohle für Stromung und
Atomenergie aber keinen Entscheidungen
die ein großes Tempo für diese
industrielle Modernisierung Deutschlands
mit sich gebracht hätten mit jeder
Windmühle mit jeder Solaranlage mit
jeder neu in Betrieb genommenen
Stromtrasse sinkt die Abhängigkeit
Deutschlands von fossilen Ressourcen die
wir aus aller Welt importieren müssen
das ist die gute Botschaft mit jeder
dieser Anlagen wird die Perspektive der
Energieversorgung auch billiger weil wir
dann auf diese Ressourcen zurückgreifen
können und mit jeder Anlage steigt die
Chance für den industriellen Umbau den
wir uns vorgenommen haben und
gleichzeitig tun wir das was notwendig
ist um das Klima zu schützen die andere
große Aufgabe die wir haben und in dem
Sinne freue ich mich sehr auf unsere
Gespräche auf Ihre Fragen und gebe Ihnen
gern meine Antworten
dann kommen wir zu fragen da hier gerade
im Saal mindestens 80 Hände gleichzeitig
hochgegangen sind arbeite ich mich jetzt
hier durch diese
ja das also der Bundeskanzler und wir
wollen das gleich mal einordnen
Deutschlands schnellste Meinung hat
Peter Thiede Peter ja das war ein
typischer Olaf Scholz ganz leise und
ganz langsam angefangen er hat natürlich
aufgezählt das haben wir alle schon
gemacht er hat sich als der große
Strategie dargestellt dass er im
Dezember vorigen Jahres schon
nachgefragt habe was ist eigentlich wenn
wir nicht genügend Gas haben was da
kannst du nicht verraten hat ist dass er
damals noch komplett auf nordstream 1
und Nord Stream 2 gesetzt hat also auf
Russen Gas und nicht davon abzubringen
weil das irgendwie zu ändern und
ansonsten war er jetzt bemüht den Leuten
etwas Sorge zu nehmen bisschen
Urlaubsstimmung noch bei zu behalten
schauen wir mal was bei den Fragen
danach herauskommt dass wir jetzt
erstmal ein entspannter Kanzler der
versucht hat entspannt auch rüber zu
kommen beim Thema Christian Lindner und
seiner Steuerentlastung bzw den Paket
was er da vorgestellt hat da hast du
auch ein bisschen gezuckt bei der
Antwort
denn wenn der Finanzminister wie gestern
geschehen wenn Christian Lindner gestern
rausgeht und ein Steuerkonzept
präsentiert mit dem die Leute die
arbeiten und Steuern zahlen entlastet
werden sollen und natürlich prozentual
die ein bisschen mehr als die anderen
und der Kanzler sagt denn jetzt nur der
Finanzminister nicht namentlich genannt
der Finanzminister habe seinen Beitrag
zu den nötigen Diskussion oder
beigetragen dann ist das schon eine
Klatsche Christian Lindner nicht
namentlich zu nennen und es nicht ein
Regierungskonzept zu nennen oder einen
Konzept der Ampel oder sein Konzept
sondern einfach nur einem Beitrag zu den
nötigen Diskussion das ist schon
wirklich hart und dann anzufügen dass
die Rentner und die Studenten da drin
nicht vorkommen dass viele ihm da muss
man dem ehemaligen Finanzminister und
heutigen Kanzler mal erklären Rentner
und Studenten zahlen jetzt nicht in dem
Maße steuern die können dann auch nicht
so entlastet werden you never walk alone
zu deutsch also wir werden euch nicht im
Stich lassen diesen Slogan des FC
Liverpool kannst dann noch mal hier also
eine
beruhigungs-tablette für die Bürger ja
ich habe schon mal gesagt der Kanzler
ist noch nicht ganz Text sicher das
natürlich die Hymne von vom FC Liverpool
stammt aber aus einem relativ kitschigen
Musical Ende der Mitte der 14er Jahre
und da kommt auch drin vor dass Raum
geht um zerstörte und weggeblasene
Träume vielleicht meint er das ja auch
dass es den Deutschen nicht mehr so gut
gehen wird und ich sage mal Erna
pachulke die das morgen ganz normal in
der Zeitung liest die liest da nicht in
der Woche alone sondern der deutsche
Kanzler kann auch ruhig mal in deutschen
Sätzen sprechen Juwel never walk alone
ja ist schön schön daher gesagt schlecht
aufgeschrieben würde mir wünschen dass
dem Kanzler dann deutscher Satz so
einfällt also die Bundespressekonferenz
läuft weiter wir werden es im
Hintergrund auch weiter verfolgen und
alle Highlights gleich im Anschluss dann
präsentieren der Bundeskanzler dort in
einer Situation muss man auch sagen die
nicht viele Kanzler vor ihm hatten so
viele Krisen auf einmal zu bewältigen
nach so kurzer Zeit im Amt vielen Dank
für den Moment
[Musik]